- [Voiceover] We're
asked to graph the circle
which is centered at 3, -2
and has a radius of 5 units.
I got this exercise
off of the Khan Academy
graph a circle according
to its features exercise.
It's a pretty neat little widget here,
because what I can do is I can
take this dot
and I can move it around
to redefine the center of the circle
so it's centered at 3, -2.
So, X is 3
and Y is -2, so that's its center.
It has to have a radius of 5.
The way it's drawn right now
it has a radius of 1.
The distance between the center
and the actual circle,
the points that define the circle,
right now it's 1.
I need to make this radius equal to 5.
If I take that,
so now the radius is equal to 2, 3, 4
and 5.
There you go.
Centered at 3, -2,
radius of 5.
Notice you go from the
center to the actual circle
it's 5 no matter where you go.
Let's do one more of these.
Graph the circle which
is centered at -4, 1
and which has the point 0, 4 on it.
Once again, let's drag the center,
so it's going to be -4,
X is -4.
Y is 1, so that's the center.
It has the point 0, 4 on it.
X is 0, Y is 4.
I have to drag,
I have to increase the
radius of the circle.
Let's see,
whoops,
nope, I want to make sure
I don't change the center.
I want to increase the
radius of the circle
until it includes this
point right over here, 0,4.
I'm not there quite yet,
there you go.
I'm now including the point 0, 4.
If we're curious what the radius is,
we could just go along the X axis.
X = -4 is the X coordinate for the center
and we see that this point ...
This is -4,1 and we see that
1,1 is actually on the circle.
The distance here is you go 4
then another 1, it's 5.
This has a radius of 5.
But either way, we did
what they asked us to do.